hi there steve kaufman
uh thank you for all the questions i'm
uh continuing my series of uh frequently
asked questions
on uh in language learning uh the first
question that was asked was
how do i deal with cases in russian or
verb endings
do i just memorize them there were other
questions about
learning you know minor languages or
what else was there i can't remember but
i'll deal with those
later so we're talking here about the
issue of case
ending noun endings or adjectives case
endings
and verb endings in russian but i think
it has application
for verb endings in other languages
romance languages and so forth
so i want to deal with this issue in
three videos
the first video will talk about the
basic concepts
the second video will talk about how one
deals with the actual
endings themselves and the third video
deals with how we get
the brain to create new neural networks
so that it will deal
with this phenomenon naturally okay
uh so with regard to concepts the basic
concept
say in russian that the endings of nouns
and adjectives
change depending on the role the
function
of the noun or adjective that's an easy
concept
so in other words whereas in english we
have prepositions
on the book in the book from the book
by the book in russian the actual word
book knight might be knee gu
knight whatever it might be
so that the the noun changes and so you
have to get your
clue about what's happening by changing
the ending of the noun and similarly
when you speak you have to change the
ending of the noun
so that's a concept that we can kind of
come to grips with
however the problem occurs when we
realize that there are so many
exceptions
for example the feminine nouns like
knight book if i read the book it's
which is then the accusative or the
direct object
and then the genitive changes kiniki and
so forth
whereas in the masculine the nominative
and the neuter the nominative
and the accusative are the same uh and
the genitive changes
however if it's an animate noun like a
person or an animal
then the accusative is the same as the
genitive
not the same as the nominative okay a
minor point if that's the only thing you
had to learn
that would be easy but when you discover
then
that uh you know if you are dealing with
one of something it's the nominative two
three or four of something
it's the genitive singular and five and
more
is the genitive plural and there are
little exceptions there depending on
whether it's masculine and feminine
the complexity starts to increase pretty
quickly
i mean i have a book here if i read you
some of the explanations you know
a b c d e f and g of
uh noun endings or aspects of verbs it's
it's
i can assure you it's tremendously
complex so the concepts
to my mind are something you can read
you have the impression you're learning
something
it's forcing you to think a little bit
about the language but you're unlikely
to make much sense of of the concepts i
mean i've been at russian for
four years and now when i read some of
these explanations
it does help me but it's taken me over a
thousand hours of listening
before these explanations actually help
me
so my advice with the concepts is get
the general
overall picture don't get too hung up
about learning the specific explanations
of what happens in this situation and
that and here's the exception and so
forth and so on because it's a thankless
task
in my opinion recognize that you will
get better at
understanding these concepts when you
have been exposed to a lot
of content through listening and reading
so that's the end of the first part
which is dealing with the
concepts